ينضم الينا الان من القاهره عبر زوم السيد
المنظري
ومدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه شرق
المتوسط دعني ابدا معك سيد احمد المنظري
عن
الاخبار التي تفصلكم حول الوضع الصحي داخل
السودان في اخبار تتضارب من هنا وهنا كان
الهلال الاحمر الصليب الاحمر يقول شيء
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه
دكتور محمد ابراهيم قال لنا على الهواء
شيء اخر يعني اقل حده من الاخبار التي يتم
تداولها
شكرا جزيلا اختي منتهى كل عام وانت بخير
وجزاكم الله خير على الاستضافه طبعا كما
هو معروف السودان مر بسنوات من الازمات
والقلاقل وعدم الاستقرار وهذا بالتالي ادى
الى هشاشه في النظام الصحي حتى قبل هذه
العزم بدات هذه العزمه والنظام الصحي
يعاني من نقص في عدد العاملين الصحيين
حشاشه حقيقيه فعلا في النظام الصحي من حيث
البنى التحتيه من حيث الاجهزه والمعدات من
حيث توفر المستلزمات الطبيه والمعدات
الطبيه الاخرى كذلك المنكده للحياه هناك
حاليا يعني حوالي مستشفى في عموم السودان
وبالاخص تسعه في الخرطوم خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب الهجمات العسكريه هناك ما يقارب من
عدد 16 مستشفى مهدده بالتوقف عن العمل
بسبب الارهاق العاملين الصحيين هناك نقص
في توفر الكهرباء والمياه النظيفه وكذلك
الغذاء للمرضى والعاملين في هذه
المستشفيات هناك صعوبه في وصول
المرضى والمصابين وكذلك الجثث نقل الجثث
والمتوفين الى المستشفيات بسبب الوضع
الامني
داخل الشارع السوداني وفي الشارع السوداني
فهو تحدي كبير الوضع الصحي وضع يعني مقلق
جدا للغايه ما هي الاجراءات المطلوبه التي
يمكن القيام بها الان من اجل تسهيل عمليه
المنظمات الطبيه داخل السودان
هو طبعا هناك ادوار مختلفه لجميع الفئات
في السودان الفئه الاولى هي الفئات
المتنازعه عليها فعلا الالتزام بما يطلق
عليه يعني وقف اطلاق النار
لساعات والايام من اجل تسهيل حركه الافراد
من اجل تسهيل وصول العاملين الصحيين الى
المستشفيات من اجل تسهيل ايصال لمساعدات
والتمويل الطبي اللازم لهذه المؤسسات
الصحيه كما ذكرت التي من نقص في الموارد
الاساسيه يعني لتقديم الخدمات الصحيه
يعني فهناك يعني يجب ان يكون التزام
التزام من جميع الافراد والفئات الموجوده
في السودان من اجل ضمان تقديم خدمات صحيه
خصوصا خلال هذه المرحله لانه هناك ما
يقارب من ثلاثه الاف مصاب تقريبا جرى هذه
النزاعات خلال الايام الماضيه هناك ما
يقارب من 300 وفاه ناتجه جراء هذه
النزاعات هناك تقريبا هجوم عسكري على عدد
من المؤسسات الصحيه هناك يعني هجوم على
سيارات اسعاف وبها مرضى وبها عاملين صحيين
فيجب على جميع الاطراف الالتزام بالمبادئ
والقيم المعروفه هل الوعد بان يتم فتح
ممرات انسانيه يمكن الوثوق به في ظل وجود
هذه الاشتباكات وهذا النزاع
والله نعمل ذلك على الرغم من انه كما
تفضلتم في التقرير هناك عدم التزام من
الاطراف المتنازعه بهذه الهدنه للاسف يعني
والوقت يمر بسرعه وهناك
وهناك فئات ضعيفه كالاطفال مهدده بمختلف
الامراض على سبيل المثال الامراض المعديه
الحصبه والملاريا والامراض الاخرى هناك
كبار بالسن يعني لم يتمكنوا من الوصول الى
صحيه هناك نساء ونساء نساء حوامل يعني
معرضات للوفاه بسبب يعني ظروف الولاده غير
السليمه في اماكن غير مناسبه جدا يعني يجب
الالتزام بالهدنه كما ذكرتم في
بتتواصلوا مع جهات في الداخل مع طرفي
النزاع من اجل ترتيب مثل هذه الاوضاع ام
لا يعني هل هل تم التواصل
نعم هو طبعا المنظمه الصحه العالميه من
ضمن مجموعه من المنظمات العموميه موجوده
في السودان هناك فريق متخصص واداره متخصصه
في الامم المتحده تجتمع بشكل مستمر تقيم
الوضع وهي على تواصل مستمر مع المكاتب
القطريه والرئيسيه لكل منظمه امميه هناك
تواصل بين هذه الفرق واداره هذه الفرق مع
الجهات المختصه في السودان سواء وزاره
الصحه الاتحاديه او الجهات المتنازعه من
خلال مختلف القنوات ففعلا هناك تواصل
ونامل من خلال هذا التواصل ان ينتج عن
فعلا يعني
التزامه بما يتم الاتفاق عليه في كثير من
المستشفيات بحسب ما ذكر لنا المتحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه السودانيه تم تحييدها عن
العمل لانها اما قريبه من من الاشتباكات
من اماكن الاشتباكات او
لاسباب اخرى بسبب الماء والكهرباء وغيرها
ما الذي يمكن عمله تجاه هذا الموضوع يعني
عدد المشافي سيكون اقل بكثير من عدد
الاصابات في حال لا سمح الله لو استمرت
الاشتباكات بهذه الطريقه
فعلا فعلا هو هذا المقلق اختي منتهى يعني
طبعا كما ذكرت هناك 16 مستشفى
اغلبيتها حوالي تسعه خرجت عن الخدمه بسبب
الهجمات على المؤسسات صحيه لا تعمل ابدا
يعني وهناك 16 مستشفى مهدده بالتوقف عن
العمل بسبب ارهاق العاملين الصحيين هناك
احتمال المزيد من هذه المؤسسات تخرج عن
الخدمه بسبب نقص الكهرباء نقص المياه نقص
الوقود هناك يعني نقص كذلك في امدادات
الدم لتقديم الخدمات اللازمه ومشتقات الدم
والادوات اللازمه لانقاذ الحياه كما يقال
عنها فهناك فعلا وضع مقلق يجب ان ننتبه
لهذا الوضع ويجب على الجميع التعاون يعني
والالتزام بتقديم كل انواع الدعم لاهلنا
في السودان في مثل هذه الحالات منظمه
الصحه العالميه بتتواصل مع دول الجوار
للدول التي تعاني مثل هذا الوضع ربما
لتسهيل تقديم المساعدات ربما لعلاقات خاصه
في الداخل تساعد المنظمه في عملها والجهات
الداخليه التابعه لها في عملها ايضا
نعم نعم كما تفضلت يعني من خلال القنوات
الخاصه يعني بمنظمه الصحه العالميه على
تواصل مع الجهات الاقليميه والعالميه من
اجل تهدئه الوضع طبعا ومن اجل كذلك ضمان
وصول افراد المجتمع الى الخدمات الصحيه
ومن اجل تمويل النظام الصحي بمختلف
المستلزمات لدينا المخزن اللوجستي لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه في اماره دبي وحاليا يجب
التنسيق على توفير المستلزمات الطبيه طبعا
كما تعلمون المداخل سواء البريه او الجويه
او البحريه للسودان مغلقه ولكن نسعى من
خلال بناء بوت سودان من عن طريق البحر
الاحمر كذلك من ايصال هذه المساعدات وكذلك
نعمل على نقل الخدمات من يعني ولايه
الخرطوم والمستشفيات المركزيه في الخرطوم
الى ولايات اخرى لم تتاثر بقرار هذه
النزاعات فهناك تنسيق داخلي وكذلك خارجه
على مستوى اقليمي ومستوى عالم يعني
بحسب ايضا المعلومات الوارده من داخل
السودان انه انه ثلاثه ارباع او اذا ما
كان اكثر من المصابين او من الذين لقيوا
حتفهم هم من المدنيين وليس من الجهات
العسكريه ما الذي
يعني ما الذي يمكن قوله في مثل هذا السياق
اذا في حال الدفع باتجاه استمرار الهدنه
اكثر فاكثر او في حال عدم استمرار هذه
الهدنه
والله هو هذا المؤسف يعني اختي منتهى
للاسف الطفيات والاصابات هي بين المدنيين
ولكن طبعا وكذلك داخل المؤسسات الصحيه
وداخل سيارات الاسعاف فهنا نناشد الاطراف
المتنازعه الالتزام
بقانون الدولي المختص بهذا الموضوع وحمايه
ارواح المدنيين خلال هذه النزاعات لكن
للاسف كما هو معروف لا يغلب يعني صوت
العقل خلال هذه المحن والازمات وانما يغلب
صوت السلاح للاسف فنناشد كذلك يعني الجميع
داخل السودان ان يلتزموا بالاخذ الحيطه
والحذر وعدم الخروج الى الاماكن الخطره
حتى يضمنوا كذلك يعني التزام الاطراف
المتنازعه بالهده وبالتالي عدم تعرض
تعرضهم للمخاطر وفقدان الارواح الكثيره
يعني هذا ممكن يكون دقيق يا دكتور احمد في
حال لو كانت العمليات العسكريه في
المفتوحه ولكن كما نشاهد العمليات
العسكريه هي داخل اماكن سكنيه وفي توزيع
وقوى عسكريه هنا وهناك ليس فقط حول
القياده العامه والمطارات او غيرها فمثل
هذه المناشده يعني قد قد لا تجد صداها في
مثل هذا الوضع الا بتجاوب الاطراف
المتحاربه هل يعني لم يكن متوقع ان يحصل
هكذا في السودان عندما كنا نتحدث عن اتفاق
اطاري لعمليه سياسيه
بمثل هذه الحالات هل تفاجئون كمنظمات
دوليه ام انه دائما لديكم استعدادات لمثل
هكذا حالات لا سمح الله
والله هو طبعا يعني نحن تفاجانا كما تفاجئ
الجميع باندلاع فتيله الحرب بين الطرفين
على الرغم على الرغم من يعني النظر الى
المؤشرات التي يعني كانت موجوده على ارض
الواقع خلال الاشهر الماضيه توحي بان هناك
نوع من الشد والجذب بين الاطراف المختلفه
داخل السودان نحن كمنظمه صحه عالميه كما
بقيه بمنظمات الامميه فنضع عده سيناريوات
من اجل ضمان توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه
كمنظمات امنيه وبالاخص منظمه الصحه
العالميه وهذا ما عملنا يعني او عكفنا
عليه خلال الاسابيع والاشهر الماضيه تمكنا
من توفير المستلزمات الطبيه في المخازن
الموجوده داخل السودان ولكن للاسف حجم
الكارثه اكبر من مقدره وزاره الصحه
والسلطات الصحيه اكبر من مقدره منظمه
الصحه العالميه وخصوصا انه منافذ الدخول
الى السودان مغلقه من اجل يعني حتى نتمكن
توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه كما تفضلتي مع
ازدياد عدد الاصابات والوفيات نحن دائما
نقدر جهودكم والمعاناه التي تشعرون بها من
امداد المساعدات في حال في الدول اللي
فيها الصراعات والازمات الف شكر لك دكتور
احمد المنظري المدير الاقليمي لمناظره
الصحه العالميه لشرق المتوسط شكرا جزيلا
على المشاركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات